une croix pour les jambes et les bras de
l'homme un point pour le foyer autant de
symbolique que les femmes berbères se
tatouent une tradition transmise à
fatima binet-ouakka par sa propre
famille
c'est pas innocent c'est parce que je
rends hommage à offin de mon bled
l'amblève qui s'appelle ait said à 60 km
de fès dans les moyen atlas
ces femmes c'est ma grand mère ma mère
mes tantes qui ont travaillé les tapis
qui en étaient tatoués et qui sont aussi
libres des corps en mouvement sur
lesquels l'artiste montre ce qu'elle
nomme des scarifications des tatouages
sur le haut du corps auquel s'ajoute le
real lourds bijoux de cheveux vire ce
bijou il intègre la personnalité de ces
femmes
il n'est plus externe il est plus
interne malgré sa lourdeur et petit à
petit vous imaginer ce qu'elle est
devenue le crash c'est la chaînette
convoi au pied aujourd'hui corps à corps
est une invitation au voyage historique
et traditionnel proposé jusqu'au mois de
novembre